-Welcome back.
Hey, it is after midnight.
So I can actually say this.
Happy birthday, pal!
It's your birthday!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
You're the first.
-I'm the very first person.
-Like, every year.
-Every year.
-Every year I'm on the show,
and you say it.
-Yeah. Do you mind me asking,
is it a big birthday?
-Listen, I was born in the '70s.
You know, December 8, '79.
-Wow.
-And the '70s were crazy,
you know?
Everybody's pooping their pants
and boobs everywhere.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, every nap I woke up,
just poop in my pants
and boobs in my face.
I thought, "Oh, yeah,
I think I like it here."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-It was a different time,
though.
The '70s were a different time.
-The '70s, yeah. 1979 exactly?
-Yeah. Yep.
-Yeah. And then the '80s.
-Everyone's learning numbers.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Everybody learned how to talk
in the '80s.
[ Laughter ]
-A wild decade that was.
-Yeah.
-Do you ever treat yourself
on your birthday?
-I did this year.
I never do but --
Listen, I really wanted to know
if I was able to evade the law.
So I hired a private
investigator to follow myself,
and I still haven't lost him.
I've been trying to lose him
a couple days.
He's good. He's good.
He doesn't know that
I hired him either.
So he, like, sends me updates.
He thinks it's a third party.
So he's like, "Yeah.
He's at the coffee shop.
He's wearing a weird jacket."
And I'm like, "I don't know
if it is a weird jacket.
I mean, it probably looks cool.
You're probably just not
very good at fashion.
Stick to the law."
[ Laughter ]
-How is your son doing?
-He's great.
-How old is he now?
-He's eight.
He's eight years old.
And I mean, he's learning stuff.
You know?
-He is, yeah.
-I didn't know it was
going to happen as quick.
You know, there's things that
you're supposed to teach him,
but there's also things you
just assume that they know.
But he got an iPad,
and I looked on it and didn't
realize there was YouTube on it.
So I'm like, "Oh, I wonder what
he's watching."
And I go in. It's mostly
Minecraft videos, you know?
And also a lot of Nick Thune
videos.
He's a big fan.
[ Laughter ]
And I saw one video
that stuck out.
It was a 30-minute video
of a person
very calmly explaining
that the Earth is flat.
[ Laughter ]
Just the red line to the end.
He devoured that video.
And I'm realizing I don't think
I've ever mentioned to him
that the Earth is round yet.
[ Laughter ]
And could you imagine if
the first thing that you ever
learn is that it's flat,
and somebody tells you in
a really convincing way,
and you look down, and you're
like, "I mean, yeah, obviously.
Yeah. It's pretty flat."
So now I'm like, "No, man.
It's round, dude."
Like, I sound like some hippie
that's like,
"Yeah, gravity, man.
And I don't get it.
Maybe it is flat. I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God, that's a terrible
way to explain.
-Yeah, I know. I don't know.
-So Daddy's a round-Earther.
-Oh, my gosh. Yeah, no, no.
It is definitely round
if you're watching --
if your son's watching.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Definitely round.
You're going back on tour.
-I am.
-This is exciting.
The Known European Tour.
-Yep, I'll be in Europe.
You know, the E.U. reached out.
They wanted me to come.
That's the European Union.
-Thank you.
We went on tour together once.
Do you remember that tour?
-Do I remember that tour?
Yeah, it was the highlight
of my life.
-That was a great tour.
-It was really fun.
You brought me
and Nate Bargatze,
and we all went around,
and Seth was there.
-Seth Herzog was there.
I remember I would do
a little bit of stand-up
and then I would introduce
my favorite comedians.
We had so much fun.
We went all around the country.
-I know, and then I remember the
first night you introduced me.
You said, "Nick Thune."
And like, I walk out, there's
thousands of people cheering.
-I know exactly what --
-And you go --
-I know exactly what you did,
because you did it
more than once.
-Yeah. But it was, like,
you'd shake my hand --
-I go, "Here he is, Nick Thune."
I go, "Break a leg man."
-Yeah, hey, thanks.
By the way, how are you doing?
-Fine, man.
-Oh, you know, let's talk about
it after my set.
-Perfect. Yeah.
And then I would leave,
but then it got longer.
-Yeah, I go, "Oh, I was going to
tell you, my mom,
she's a big fan."
[ Laughter ]
-Everyone's clapping.
I go, "Ladies and gentlemen,
Nick Thune."
Everyone claps. You walk out.
I shake your hand, you're like,
"Hey, man, do you want to,
like, hang out afterwards?
And we'll have dinner. Like,
what would you want to eat?
Like, would you want to eat
Italian food?
Or would you want to have
Chinese food?
Oh, you know what? Never mind.
Let's eat in the hotel room."
-And then I'd pitch you on
some of my business ideas.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, what do you think about
scented Wi-Fi?"
[ Laughter ]
"I think we're gonna go big.
I think we're gonna go big."
-That made me laugh so hard.
I loved it.
It got longer and longer
every time I'd introduce you.
I go, "Oh, my gosh,
this guy is amazing."
I want to talk about also --
You're going on tour.
Known European Tour.
But also you're starring in
this film, "Mixtape."
It's a beautiful movie,
by the way.
It is funny,
but it's also very touching.
It's a nice family movie if you
guys want to check it out.
-You know, I, um...
No, I'm not going to say it.
I will say it.
I love you.
[ Audience aws ]
-You weren't going to say it?
-I wasn't going to say it.
-Why weren't you going to
say it?
-Because I was taught
to bury my emotions.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my goodness.
But now it's your birthday.
-I'm here.
-Well, can I just say something
to you?
-Yeah.
-I love you.
[ Audience aws ]
There you go.
-I also love YouTube.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, did you say "tube"?
-Yeah, I was talking about
YouTube.
-Oh, my God. Sorry about that.
Yeah, I know, I love YouTube.
-Huge misunderstanding.
-So sorry, that was weird.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Nick Thune in "Mixtape."
Take a look at this.
-Which song do you want?
Whichever is the best.
-Didn't you say
it was a mixtape?
-It's from a tape of songs
my parents put together?
-Yeah, then you have listen to
the songs in order, okay?
A mixtape is a message from the
maker to the listener, right?
It's not just about which songs,
but in what order.
Microseconds between segues.
Tempo changes.
Does it fade out?
Does it fade in?
Does it matter to you? Okay?
Alright. Getting nowhere fast.
Girls that are best.
Great.
Hands off and stand there.
-Message from the maker.
-Ah! Nick Thune, everybody!
"Mixtape" is streaming now
on Netflix.